economic recovery next generation eu
here to
record time for the own resources
decision
to be taken in five months or ratified
in five months
we had the experience the bad experience
of the financial crisis
10 years a decade ago almost 3
trillion of liquidity was offered
then we had the bridging part of 550
billion one part of it is
the shore element with 100 billion and
now the recovery with 750 billion next
generation eu
here we look today um at the
national plans we have now 24 national
plans
submitted 12 of those are approved
there too i want to thank you antonio
because you have been pushing
hard that we are fast
of course it is needed in our economies
and yes
um until the uh end of the month
until the end of your presidency you
will have reached your goal that
there is a good chunk of plans approved
ready to go if we look at the plans
um they all include a significant subset
of country-specific recommendations that
is
reforms and a lot of investment
if we look at our targets all plans
meet or overshoot the target of
investing
20 percent in the digital the same goes
for the green
37 at least they meet it if not
a lot of them overshoot it and that is
good so we will have an investment of at
least 200
billion euros in green measures
just to name a few topics
but there is also a strong investment in
the social dimension
so youth employment child care higher
education
health care just to name a few topics it
is now for the council
to adopt the plans in the next or those
who are approved in the next four weeks
and then we are ready to disperse
because we have
launched the bond issuance program
already last week
it was very successful we have raised 20
billion euros
with a maturity of 10 years and it was
seven times over subscribed which shows
the trust and the confidence of the
markets
in next generation eu and in the
european union